hello everyone just a longing here today
for this knot episode of play watch
listen after a conversation earlier in
the week with myself
Austin Troy and Mike we decided like
many others that we didn't want to do
the show this week in very large part
because we didn't want to take any kind
of spotlight away from the much more
important conversations that are
happening right now frankly also on
other podcasts that I would love to see
anyone who listens to this show put
their time towards a huge shout out to
it's just one of many about the spawn on
me podcast an amazing show this week
I'll leave a link in the description
below if there's an hour you spend
watching us I would love to see you
spend that hour watching and listening
to them instead this week so I'll link
that in case you guys want to but we
also wanted to say first of all thank
you to everyone who listens to this show
it's a huge privilege and it's one of
the most positively received things I've
ever done to the extent that sometimes
people do ask if they can support the
show financially which up until this
point I have basically not allowed so to
anyone who's ever asked to do anything
like that we do have some causes that we
would love to see you donate to I
particularly set up a fundraising
campaign in the name of George Floyd
that is currently at sixty three
thousand dollars and I would love to see
that get high up before the date ends
and if the player which listen community
wants to get in on on that I will leave
a link in the description to where you
can do that that would be awesome to
have your input there but we also wanted
to give a shout out to the Innocence
Project which works to overturn bad
convictions and exonerate current
inmates plus two a series of black owned
businesses that were destroyed due to
the riots so again I will leave links in
the description on the YouTube video I
may not be able to do that on the audio
version so I'll probably just give you
the titles but there are also some
organizations that you can support such
as reclaim the block north style health
collective the NAACP Legal Defense Fund
black visions collective black
disability coalition the Marshall
project ACLU campaign zero and the
Advancement Project it would really mean
the world to us if you would throw some
support behind
of these causes thank you for listening
to the show I hope everyone is doing
okay and we will see you around
thank you